N
FINALLY TELL THE TRUTH EVERY
ONCE IN A WHILE ON TV.
ALSO LITTLE DISAPPOINTED IN
THEIR COWARDICE.
HE AND BUCK SEXTON HOST THE SHOW
AND WE ARE HAPPY TO HAVE THEM ON
TONIGHT.
CLAY, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
IT DOES SEEM LIKE WE ARE FINALLY
ALLOWED A LITTLE BIT OF AIR.
PROGRESS?
>> TUCKER, FIRST, THANKS FOR
HAVING ME.
SECOND, THESE GUYS COME I THINK
BEFORE LONG BELLMAWR AND JON
STEWART, SOMEBODY FLIPPED THEM A
RED PILL PAID THE NEXT THING YOU
KNOW THEY ARE GOING TO START
GETTING ACCUSED OF BEING
FOX NEWS BECAUSE THEY SOUND LIKE
SOMEBODY WHO'S BEEN HEARING THE
TRUTH FOR THE PAST YEAR AS
OPPOSED TO MARINATING IN THE
ABSURDITY THAT IS THE CONSISTENT
OPINION PAIRED HERE'S WHAT I
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE AS A GLIMMER
OF HOPE.
COMEDY IS SUPPOSED TO BE ABOUT
REBELLION.
IT ISN'T SUPPOSED TO BE ABOUT
ENFORCING THE DOGMA OF THE
POLITICAL PARTY THAT IS IN
POWER.
AND FINALLY WE ARE STARTING TO
SEE A LITTLE BIT OF REBELLION
FOR OLD BILL MAHER.
IT'S TIME TO PUNCTURE THE
REALITY OF THE MAJORITY PARTY
THAT ITS RULING WITH A LOT OF
ABSURDITY.
THIS IS THE EMPEROR WEARS NO
CLOSE MOMENT.
TO ME, THEY DEFINITELY FEEL RED
BILLED, AND I LOVE IT.
>> YOU MAKE SUCH A GOOD POINT.
COMEDY ART IS SUPPOSED TO BE
ABOUT REBELLION.
IT'S RAISING A MIDDLE FINGER IN
THE PHASE AND SAYING YOU HAVE A
SPECIAL EXEMPTION TO SEE WHAT IS
ABSOLUTELY TRUE AND EVERYBODY
KNOWS AND YOU CAN'T DO ANYTHING.
I MEAN, HOW SHAMEFUL IS IT THAT
WE WAIT A YEAR AND A HALF FOR
SOMEONE TO FINALLY DO THAT?
I'VE BEEN TIMING AT THIS WHOLE
TIME.
>> I'VE BEEN WAITING FOR IT.
AND I'M CAUTIOUSLY OPTIMISTIC
HERE THAT WHAT IS STARTING TO
HAPPEN IS WE ARE SEEING A
REVOLUTION AGAINST THE WILKE
UNIVERSE.
AND THAT IS GOING TO BE LEAD, I
REALLY BELIEVE THIS, BY CREATIVE
PEOPLE.
BY ARTISTS WHO ARE GOING TO SAY
WAIT A MINUTE, YOU ARE
CONSTRAINING MY ABILITY TO
COMMENT ON THE LARGER CULTURE
WHEN YOU LOOK AT EVERY ONE OF MY
JOKES AND TRY TO DISSECT IT TO
SEE WHETHER OR NOT THE FACULTY
IS HAPPY WITH THE JOKE THAT I'VE
TOLD.
WITH ALL OF THIS CONSTRAINT
MEANT OCCURRING, WHAT TYPICALLY
IS GOING TO BE THE RESPONSE IS A
ROBUST, JUST ABSOLUTE IN PRAISE
OF CREATIVITY.
AND YOU CAN'T BE CREATIVE WHILE
BEING STIFLED WITHIN THE BOUNDS
OF WHAT THE LEFT WING CULTURE IS
CREATING.
AND I THINK WHAT YOU ARE
STARTING TO SEE FROM JON STEWART
AND FROM BILL MAHER -- THESE ARE
NOT PEOPLE WHO ARE KNOWN TO BE
PARTICULARLY RIGHT WING IN
NATURE, BUT WHAT THEY ARE
EMBRACING THIS FREEDOM BUT I
THINK WHAT WE ARE STARTING TO
CREATE HERE IS A WORLD WHERE YOU
ARE EITHER FOR FREEDOM ARE YOU
ARE AGAINST IT.
AND COMEDIANS, BY THEIR NATURE,
HAVE TO REBEL AGAINST ANYONE WHO
IS OPPOSED TO FREE THOUGHT.
>> Tucker: MAN, I HOPE YOU ARE
RIGHT.
NOT ONE THING HAS BEEN CREATED
IN THIS COUNTRY.
NOT ONE THING.
ONLY DESTROYED.
>> I KNOW.
THE MINUTE THE CREATIVITY
STARTS --
>> FOX NEWS IN GENERAL.
WHETHER THEY WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
IT OR NOT, GIVING THESE GUYS THE
SPACE TO MAKE THE ARGUMENTS THAT
THEY ARE MAKING NOW, EVEN IF
THEY CONSIDER FOX NEWS VIEWERS
TO BE A INSULT, THE REASON WHY
THEY CAN DO THAT -- AND I WILL
REPEAT THIS TOO.
ALL OF THOSE PEOPLE LAUGHING IN
THE STEPHEN COLBERT AUDIENCE,
THEY WOULD'VE BEEN CALLING
ANYBODY WHO MADE THE COMMENTS
THAT JON STEWART DID OVER THE
PAST YEAR A CONSPIRACY THEORIST,
NOW THEY ARE ENJOYING THE
ABSURDITY FROM WHAT THEY
BELIEVE.
>> Tucker: YOU MAKE A GOOD
POINT.